[Musique]
dans mektoub my love abdellatif kechiche
à qui on doit déjà la graine et le mulet
ou la vida d'elle nous raconte
l'histoire damine apprentis scénariste
d'installer à paris qui revient à 7 le
temps d'un été
et c'est indispensable pourquoi parce
que allons-y le film à ce délicieux
parfum de sexe qui nous rappelle l'été
tout tout transpire cette hauteur du
sexe après la plage les corps encore ça
les crimes et lascif cambrai sauvage
les cheveux encore mouillés de la
baignade les torts soucek des garçons
les poitrines généreuses des filles tout
vraiment tout prend une connotation
gourmande manger des fraises ouvrir des
bières fumer des cigarettes est encore
plus ses moments de rien ses silences
ses regards intenses profond sans issue
[Musique]
et alors qu'on est quand même à deux
doigts de se dire que kechiche en fait
un poil trop à force de zoom sur les
maillots une pièce en lycra cheap et sur
les short en jeans trop court on bascule
on bascule vers notre adolescence vers
la découverte de la sensualité vers les
interrogations amoureuse
les histoires les secrets et jalousie ou
pense à rohmer un peu parfois
un revers qui aurait emmené pauline dans
le sud et qu'il aurait refusé à
l'esthétique des années 90 des
restaurants exotiques arrêtés peu
douteuse au poët tenue avec de la
moquette murale qui sont le tabac froid
[Musique]
et si nos yeux finissent par être ébloui
c'est parce que kechiche travail la
lumière comme personne tellement que
c'est elle plus qu'à mines le personnage
principal tellement qu'un halo rose se
forment sur notre rétine
soit exactement ce qui se passe quand on
cite le soleil un peu trop longtemps
alors sans le décider vraiment on
s'abandonne à la jouissance comme quand
on fait basculer notre nuque vers
l'arrière sur notre serviette pour mieux
s'offrir aux uv pour que s'offrir
plaisir pour bien s'offrir au désir pour
mieux s'offrir au cinéma
[Musique]